by the way I should say welcome back to
the show if you've been kind enough to
Grace us with your presence before no
thank you for having me and having me
back of course thank you for trusting us
wait you have an entire Betty Boop room
in your house I do it's yeah
um I just like I fell in love with Betty
Boop when I was like four and I started
collecting her and then I found out that
she the original Betty Boop was a black
jazz singer named Esther see I didn't
know this yeah how how did you find that
out and was she based on a real person
or she was based on a real person
um and for me it was kind of like I just
fell in love with her because she was
the unassuming Beauty and growing up
where I did we were like one of one
black family and so there's a lot of
different things I dealt with but I
always felt like I know that I'm dope
they just don't know it yet you know and
so to me like Betty represented kind of
like the the unassuming Beauty and then
when I researched her she was a living
breed thing black Jazz uh singer that's
so interesting how come this isn't a
more well-known fact and thank you for
teaching it to us
[Applause]
she's like a cultural icon based on a
black female jazz singer yeah yeah named
Esther
um you worked with a friend
um I can't believe I get to say he's a
friend
um Curtis 50 Cent Jackson
but he is hey yeah
yeah I was in the 21 Questions music
video when I was 21. and um
look at that
um you said that that was like a turning
point in your career yeah doing that
video why may I ask why
um I was at that weird kind of
transitional stage where I was still you
know playing 14 15 16 years old and I
was like 21 and you know as you know
being a child actor that transition is
very hard because people just kind of
want you to stay and you were a child
actor yeah yeah and so
um for me it was it was kind of like a
National Commercial saying I am grown I
am a woman now you know well music
videos were so important oh for sure you
know since that MTV flag landed on that
Moon up until you know very recently
like and they're still very important
but they were everything yeah like that
was yeah they were a huge medium and
format and it's true there is sort of
one way to dispel the I'm a little girl
now and you know being in a cool 50 Cent
video or like for me I did a film called
Poison Ivy it's like you're like
[Applause]
that movie by the way oh my God so much
well congratulations on season two of
Harlow thank you
I did not realize that the writer of
girls trip is the one who went and made
this series happen because Pearl trip is
the greatest yeah it's awesome and
Harlem is really loved and in fact we
have a clip why don't we take a look
did you bring my diet coke
I texted you text right um I think I
actually left my phone at home and I was
getting my work stuff I can go back yes
but that would leave me sitting here and
waiting and waiting is not my thing
did I just get a waft of liquor on your
breath no that is French champagne it's
not actually alcohol well let's leave
that conversation for you and your
sponsor at some future twice a minute
[Music]